die frage warum oder inwiefern das thema
digitalisierung die philosophie
interessant sein sollte muss im jahr 250
21 und eigentlich schon seit den
achtziger jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts mit einer gegenfrage
beantwortet werden die natürlich lautet
aus welchem grund sollte philosophie
sich nicht interessieren denn unter der
voraussetzung dass wir das hier heute
nicht nur eine historische auf selbst
exegese beschränkte disziplin ist
sondern sie nach wie vor ort den
anspruch hat etwas über die welt und die
gegenwart auszusagen wird auch die
philosophie nicht mehr umhin können
zu konstatieren dass die digitale
transformation den unhintergehbaren
horizont unserer zeit bildet den man
auch dann nicht sich entziehen kann wenn
man versucht ihn zu negieren oder zu
ignorieren
die arbeit beginnt sybille krämer hat
das genauso eingeführt mit der
begrifflichkeit in der momentan
gesellschaftlichen diskussion von großer
verwirrung geprägt dass wir alle wissen
welches mitunter sehr schwer macht
überhaupt über die dinge zu reden deren
dringlichkeit gleichwohl allen
beteiligten wenn auch oft nur diffus wie
er bewusst ist
du bist zum beispiel ich mache jetzt
kurz zu fragen auf der begriff digitale
hier überhaupt genau genug ist dass den
bekannten gründen denn uns allen ist ja
klar
spätestens seit heute morgen das digital
und diskrete medien so alt wie die
mediengeschichte selbst als nicht mit
dem computer beginnen sollen bereits mit
der schrift zum beispiel ist also der
begriff des digitalen zwar nicht völlig
falsch aber ein wenig zu unspezifisch
könnte die alternative zum beispiel den
begriff des algorithmischen liegen
ebenfalls ein terminus mit einer langen
geschichte der allerdings seit den
fünfziger sechziger jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts im zusammenhang mit dem
computer und damit meine ich jetzt immer
neumann von neumann architektur +
tormaschine eine spezifische bedeutung
erhält und eine bestimmte technisch
realisierte mathematisch formalisierte
verfahrensweise meint deren systeme
gesellschaft auf globaler ebene
inzwischen durchdringt derlei ist daher
keine technologisches glasperlenspiel
sondern hat konkrete auch
bildungspolitische auswirkungen denn wer
glaubt es reiche aus glasfaserleitung
auszubauen und wifi + tablet sind die
schulen zu bringen verkennt
das mit der aufrüstung durch hardware
überhaupt nichts gewonnen ist lange die
diesem medium zu grunde liegenden
prinzipien unverstanden bleiben da wären
wir mitten in der digitalen aufklärung
die ständige regel rede von black box
ist die wir auch heute wieder öfters
gehört haben etwa auch im zusammenhang
mit die burning aber im zusammenhang mit
computeroberfläche überhaupt also die
auffassung man müsse in bezug auf ki zum
beispiel nicht wie sie zu ihren
ergebnissen kommen ist eigentlich kaum
mehr als ein reflex dieses unverständnis
oder noch konkreter es bringt nichts
kindern und jugendlichen in der schule
irgendwelche programme beizubringen oder
hart während die hände zu geben die in
einem jahr sowieso wieder veraltet sind
sondern es käme darauf an eine ahnung
davon vermitteln was algorithmische
denken würde was die spezifische
rationalität oder auch irrationalität
des algorithmischen ausmacht das ist
sowohl für eine bewusste nutzung
algorithmischer medien als auch für den
kritischen umgang mit diesem jahr von
entscheidender bedeutung hier kommt die
für so viel spielen
ich habe heute nicht elf thesen ich hab
nur eine ich möchte für folgende da nur
ein aspekt heraus greifen meine these
lautet dass eine der großen
philosophischen herausforderung unserer
zeit dahin besteht dass einige probleme
und prozesse durch algorithmische medien
entscheidbar werden bereits geworden
sind die es vorher nicht warum schreit
auch gar nicht sein sollten dies hat
eine verschärfung der concept konzepte
vom war englisch griechisch rss
lateinisch elexxion und entscheidung im
städtischen griechisch kairos lateinisch
die cdu zur folge die beide begriffe in
einem zunehmend agon ahles verhältnisse
zu dortigen kreuzung bisschen
beschränken was hier auf dem spiel steht
dass sich vielleicht am einfachsten
anhand des selbstfahrenden autos und
damit zusammenhängenden berühmten trolle
problem illustrieren können viele von
ihnen wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr
höher ist mir klar aber es ist nun mal
sehr bekannter deswegen auch sehr zu
handeln also einem klassiker der
digitalen moralphilosophie der den
vorteil hat durch die immer wieder neu
aufflammende diskussion stets
aktualisiert zu werden und sehr bekannt
zu sein es gibt mehrere versionen dieses
gedankenexperiment jedoch ist das
grundproblem stets dass er über ein
bahnwärter sieht dass eine bahn waggon
in der trolli außer kontrolle geraten
ist und um unaufhaltbar auf eine
menschenmenge zu gast die sich auf dem
gleis befindet die einzige wahl die der
bemitleidenswerte stellenwert hat ist
eine weichenstellung auszulösen den
wagen auf ein nebengleis lenkt wo nur
ein paar bahnarbeiter überfahren werden
würden
ein anfall wesentlich kleiner ist als
die der mensch auf dem anderen
die alternative wäre nichts zu tun und
dem wagen einfach seinen lauf zu lassen
wie soll dieser bahnwärter nun aber
wählen oder sich entscheiden
und hier ist man punkt denn ob es sich
hier um eine wahl oder eine entscheidung
handelt ist dabei nicht einer sondern
kern des problems
wir sehen bereits unmittelbar das den
bern dem bahnwärter eine handlungsoption
schon mal nicht gegeben ist nämlich jene
sich nicht zu entscheiden
denn auch ein nichthandeln wäre ja eine
entscheidung in diesem fall sogar eine
sehr schwerwiegende es gibt also
sozusagen in dieser situation keine
barbie option mehr die sich komplett
raus hält
auf diesen prozess der entscheidung
dieses gedankenexperiment ist ein
beliebter denksport in ethik seminaren
und es gibt viele mögliche lösungen
seitdem das problem in den 60er jahren
das erste mal formuliert wurde
wichtig ist jedoch dass dieses dilemma
unter den vorzeichen algorithmischer
kulturen noch tiefgreifender ist und
seine möglichen lösungswege bereits
erahnen lassen was eigentlich problem
besteht nämlich jetzt nicht daran wie
der bahn nähert er sich entscheidet denn
dann befindet sich immer zwischen skylla
und charybdis kommt er gar nicht raus
sondern darin dass diese situation
überhaupt entscheid bar geworden durch
diese prämisse ist das fatale nach
lateinisch warum also das im
buchstäblichen sinne schicksalhaft
ausweglose der ganzen situation bereits
länger längst pre determiniert das neue
der algorithmischen umwälzung unserer
zeit sowie gefahren und chancen einer
künftigen künstlichen intelligenz
entspringen unter anderem genau dieses
dilemma wenn auch vielen ebenen unseres
lebens fühlen wir uns ermöglicht durch
digitale medien vermehrt in der
situation des bahnwärters jeder der weiß
was auf ihn zukommt und nun zur
entscheidung gezwungen ist das
eigentliche dilemma dabei ist aber
folgendes wir können uns hier nicht
richtig entscheiden denn wir haben keine
wahl
die unterscheidung von entscheidung und
war es ja für mich maßgebend das
selbstfahrende automarkt das
illustrieren im falle eines unfalls
unfalls reagieren menschen in pkws er
artig unvorhersehbar und vorhersehbar
die vorgänge im moment eines autounfalls
ereignen sich so schnell dass wir nicht
bewusst wählen sondern nur reagieren die
meisten menschen waren auch tieren auf
obwohl jeder weiß dass man damit andere
verkehrsteilnehmer und sich selbst ja
gefährdet
wie sieht es dann erst auf einer
belebten kreuzung aus auf den mann im
bruchteil einer sekunde entscheiden soll
ob nun die junge mutter mit dem
kinderwagen die gruppe von zwölf
radfahrern oder man sich selbst tötet
wir können das nicht wählen denn wir
reagieren in dem moment deswegen
verweisen juristische begriffe in diesem
zusammenhang immer auf kontingents so
heißt es beispielsweise unfall weil es
sich hier nicht einfach nur ein
ausnahmefall handle sondern um das
buchstäbliche undenkbare dass im moment
des ereignisses mit bewusstem denken
oder freier wahl nichts zu tun hat es
gehört zu unserem dasein dass wir mit
solchen einbrüchen des unvorhersehbaren
zufälligen oder auch chaotischen umgehen
müssen
ohne das wäre wie der bahnfahrer die
dinge von weitem kommen sehen kann
dazu gehören nicht nur zeitliche
faktoren wie am beispiel des autounfalls
sondern auch ein zuviel an variablen
wird wenn der choice preis der options-
paradiese diese situation haben als in
der realität der lebenswelt nichts mit
den willensäußerung eines objekts
sondern mit einer fülle von strukturen
zu tun welche die person selbst nicht
zum subjekt zum objekt der entscheidung
werden lässt daher sind entscheidungen
wie niklas luhmann sagt vor allem ein
kommunikatives ereignis und nicht etwas
was im kopf eines individuums
stattfinden wir stoßen das ist auch
heute aufgefallen
bei der diskussion immer wieder an die
grenze der von innen und außen und dann
kommt immer wieder zu dem schluss dass
das einzig relevante außen passiert also
in einem raum der aushandlung oder der
ja also an einem app islamischen raum
sozusagen der zwischen den akten
funktioniert das ist eine der sachen die
sie ich sehr wichtig finde mich
interessiert dann immer der der spieler
begriffe ich den auch aus einem
systemischen raum sehe der in einem
außen liegt also die ex frau sybille
krämer nennt das die ex terrorisierung
des geistes also eine an nach draußen
verlegen das ist ja das richtige
dies ist ein wichtiger aspekt des
entscheidungsbedarf nämlich der umstand
dass im gegensatz zur wahl
entscheidungen immer von äußeren
faktoren abhängig sind und getrieben
sind
das ist bereits im griechischen kairos
angesprochen der jenen glücklichen
moment meint der ergriffen werden muss
und auch verpasst werden kann
die wahl im sinne der herr es ist
hingegen wie die in dehrn ii komischen
ethik dann folgenreich so pro harris ist
der vorzugs wahl wird ist auf das
handeln bezogen und letztlich von der
gegenwart aus und er unglücklich
formuliert eine mehr oder weniger
reflektierte willens osten ich verkürzte
hier ein überaus vielgestaltigen
philosophiegeschichte mit einigen
verwerfungen umdeutungen die es schon
aristoteles über willen von ob
kirkegaard den existenzialismus bis zum
mathematischen spieltheorie und deren
grundprämisse des der rachel joyce
reicht auch so ein problematischer wahl
begriff daher eigentlich entscheidungen
gemeint ist also um das bisschen zu
klären will ich ganz kurz die
semantischen felder beider begriffe so
ein bisschen im reifen wir sind ja jetzt
ein glück in einem philosophischen
umkreis
die begriffe selektion im lateinischen
pro hieß es in griechischen industries
französisch vor der eine schwald oder
polnisch wie bohr gehören alle zur
ideologie der war das althochdeutsche
wellen aus dem achten jahrhundert ist
nach der wurzel wollen gebildet und
bedeutet sinngemäß möglichkeit
stimmung nach eigenem ermessen nach
freiem entschluss freiem willen
vorher beigeordneten sind und
jugendgruppe gehören auswahl aus
lösungen auslese sorry selektion
präferenz bevorzugung stets schwingt
dabei ein freiheitlicher zwang leser
zwangloser jedoch nicht willkürlich ag
ist es in diesen worten mit das
griechische heer ist das etwa wahl
anschauung oder schule im sinne von
denkschule meint ist noch als negativ
vorher inbegriff der häresie aufgehoben
dass wir ja alle noch kennen meine
aussage oder lehrer die im widerspruch
vor dominieren grau glaubensgrundsätzen
steht pro rss ist als wahl begriff ist
den ikonischen ethik dagegen ein eng mit
dem handeln vernünftigen verknüpfter
termins die vorsilbe pro macht deutlich
dass der wahl immer eine überlegung
vorausgeht daher die kanonisierte
übersetzung der vorzugs wahl war es
total ist welche eine ab meint denn der
welt etwas macht wählen ist aktiv an die
nation in der welt die mit der wahl
verbundene überlegung ist wiederum in
der die harris als
unterscheidungsvermögen sinne eines
durchdeklinieren von wahlmöglichkeiten
aufgehoben unterscheiden und darauf
kunstmann unterscheiden ist kein
entscheiden sondern eine entfaltung von
potenzen das ist übrigens eine glaube
ich schon kurz fassen lassen was
philosophie eigentlich tut
zum
entscheidung kurz das griechische kairos
hingegen ist ein religiös
philosophischer begriff für den
günstigen zeitpunkt eine entscheidung
das ungenutzte zu streichen
nach nachteilig sein kann interessant
ist hier der zeitliche aspekt der im
moment der urteilssprechung erahnen
lässt der entscheidung eignet etwas
moment haftet und endlich ist das durch
eine äußere absolutheit gesetzt wird die
wahl dagegen ist immer andauernden
neuwahl des selbst zu verstehen
lateinische decio das dänische autor
else oder das polnische die glaube ich
komme technologisch von scheiden teilen
trennen beilegen so weiter sind sie auch
im sinne eines juridischen entscheids
und beige
sie sind teil der firmengruppe beschluss
wille ratlos urteil oder das letzte wort
im moment wird ergriffen dieses
ergreifen wird dabei jedoch von außen
bestimmt von dem was ergriffen wird
entscheidende stone grunde reaktiv man
könnte somit sagen dass das letzte wort
dann auch politisch gesprochen vor allem
deswegen relevant ist weil die
entscheidung letztlich eine aus der
reaktion erzwungene scheinaktivitäten
möchte man nun ein selbst fahren das
auto konstruieren so hätte man eine ki
zu entwerfen die eine wahl treffen kann
wobei nicht bedacht wird dass computer
eben nicht wählen sondern entscheiden
und letzteres ist für ein computer
computer ja auch überhaupt kein problem
denn dessen technischer kern um eine
einzige sache herum konzipiert die sich
einer unumstößlichen prämisse äußert
dass die probleme mit denen sich ein
computer befasst formalisierter und das
heißt entscheid basis
rechengeschwindigkeit und speicherplatz
lösen dann heute zusätzlich das problem
der zeit und der variablen die
geschwindigkeit von rechenoperationen
unterschreitet jedes reaktionsvermögen
und big data processing kommt eine
vielzahl an variablen mühelos zurecht
das ist das wunder der des maschinen und
das warum dann auch immer so quasi
religiöse projektionen darf man also in
diesem ganzen black box und ich weiß
nicht was die eigentlich macht wie sie
zu ihren ergebnis kommt es auch immer so
einen so eine reine eine ende sein
erschauern wie vom wie vom welfischen
orakel das ist das beobachtet man häufig
an dieser stelle aber und darauf kommt
es mir an haben wir es nicht mit
ethischen fragen zu tun sondern in bezug
auf rechner technologien mit deren
medien technischen voraussetzungen
und an dieser stelle kommt wie gesagt
geh ins spiel was gemäss der erklärung
die uns informatiker ingenieurs kunst
geben heute anders sei es noch so ein
paar jahren ist formuliert im licht hat
es eben gesagten das computer heute
nicht mehr sklavisch an programmablauf
wolken welcher form die entscheidung
festlegen sondern durch sogenannte stop
oder machine learning und andere ähnlich
strukturierte verfahren in die lage
versetzt sein selbstständig zu wählen
mit betonung auf selbstständig das könne
die ki weil sie aus einer datenbank
schöpft die millionen von
unfallsituationen enthält und diese
datenmenge dann entsprechend auswerten
kann
doch was heißt hier aus werden welcher
wert mit hier ermittelt durch die hohe
datenmenge das ist schon einiges mal
angeklungen heute durch die hohe
datenmenge können der computer
situationen oder können computer
situation statistisch beurteilen und
durch die hohe rechengeschwindigkeit
wählen welcher der mensch bloß reagiert
wir sehen endlich die wahl letztendlich
an parametern wie der datenmenge und
verarbeitungsgeschwindigkeit nur das
eine ki damit nicht mehr überfordert sei
das so lautet zumindest ist das
versprechen
die frage ist jedoch nach welchen
kriterien hier eigentlich ausgewählt
wird
und da sind wir auch an einem punkt der
gerade kamen was zum beispiel die
auswertung von sommer hochliteratur bis
sein könnte wie kann man das
quantifizieren nämlich irgendwie nämlich
keine ahnung
die komplexität der syntax nehme ich
eine eine verwandlung alleine eine zu
einer häufung von neologismen oder fremd
worten oder oder wie und das land zähle
das und dann wird das irgendwie ist das
hochliteratur also ist ganz schwierig
weil natürlich auch hochliteratur gibt
wie ich kenne kazuo ishiguro glaube ich
nur werden die literaturnobelpreisträger
der betont einfacher sprache also es ist
eben nicht wird man ja wohl vor der raum
bogen ganz betont schlichte sprache
verwendet also das sind alles dinge
welche kriterien setzen wir hier an
welcher wert wird hier ermittelt durch
die hohe datenmenge können der computer
situation statistisch beurteilen und
durch die hohe rechengeschwindigkeit
wählen welche der mensch bloß reagiert
das ist so derbe punkt
frage ist wie gesagt nach welchen
kriterien wählen
das gesetzbuch kann hier nicht
weiterhelfen wenn es kennt der
menschliche situation entsprechende
unfall und vorsatz mit dem interessanten
sonderfall der fahrlässigkeit der
allerdings juristisch er der sphäre des
vorsatzes angehört und ähnlich wenn auch
wesentlich schwächer bestraften dadurch
dass die situationen darauf kommt es
jetzt an dadurch dass die situation im
falle der ki moon aber durch die
geschwindigkeitsvorteile entscheidbar
geworden dass gibt es streng genommen
kein unfall mehr in diesem juridischen
sinne der rechner ist viel schneller und
kann entscheiden was zu machen ist alle
kiz und zaudert auch nicht wenn die ki
entscheiden soll ob das auto katze
kleinkind oder rentner überfährt so muss
man sich darüber so muss man darüber ins
instruiert werden wer oder was hier zu
bevorzugen ist
im einen fall ist es juristisch noch
klar wenn zwischen katze und mensch
unterschieden werden muss
aber was passiert wenn man zwischen
kleinkind und rentner
entscheiden muss wer stirbt und erlebt
wenn die ki moon die planning millionen
unfälle in echtzeit analysieren kann so
wird sie darauf keine für uns
befriedigend verziehen können weil es
eben bei unfällen nicht zu
entscheidungen kommen sondern
kontingents hier die hauptrolle spielt
das heißt auf der ki dann zur verfügung
steht sind statistische wert aus der
vergangenheit auch ein punkt auf den
herbst vor kurzem marco hingewiesen
hatten also die die statistische
auswertung ist jetzt fang ist ja
zwangsläufig konservativ im sinne dass
sie immer nur vergangenheit orientieren
werden kann
das ist auch das problem bei der
voraussage man kann auf der
vergangenheit nicht die zukunft
modellieren oder nur ganz in sehr
begrenzten maßstäben das ist ein großes
problem bei der modellierung
dabei kann
es kommen bei dieser speziellen
statistischen auswertung aus der
vergangenheit dass kinder in der
vergangenheit oft gestorben sind als
rentner und katzen aber was soll eine ki
daraus schließen
sie kann nur einem statistischen
konservativismus folgenden was ihr
passiert ist keine entfaltung von
potenzial i tät welche
zukunftsgerichteten aussagen ab gleich
an statistische werte die nur
vergangenheitsbezogene urteil können
canon probleme fangen dann schon bei den
besitzverhältnissen anderen wäre würde
ein auto kaufen das im falle eines
unfalls altruistisch reagiert also zb
die eigene fahne person opfert um etwa
ein bus voller kinder vor dem sicheren
tod zu bewahren
eine ki hat keine wahlmöglichkeit für
letztere nicht auf statistischen werten
resultieren können statistiken und
datenmengen müssen nach anderen
gesichtspunkten gefiltert werden und
diese filterung kann nicht technisch
automatisiert vorausgesetzt werden
und zwar in scheiben und das schneller
als jeder mensch oder es ist ihnen
jedoch völlig wesensfremd ihre ob danach
zu fragen für was man sich warum
entscheiden kann
es fehlt das moment der reflektierenden
abwägung computer können nicht wählen
oder anders formuliert es besteht ein
kategoriale graben zwischen der ebene
des quantitative und der des
qualitativen denn ich einfach durch
addition von daten oder aktuelle ration
von verarbeitungsgeschwindigkeit
überwunden
das ist auch wissen dass negativ gewesen
also wir müssen nun abwarten bis die
rechner schnell genug die datenmengen
groß genug und die das ram irgendwie
nicht mehr 8 sondern 32 gb oder was
immer hat und dann wird es irgendwann zu
dem punkt kommen
so sinke daher zwar singularität oder
was also dass das würde ich zum beispiel
nicht unterschreiben
zum schluss lässt sich zusammenfassend
vielleicht die situation sagen dass wir
das zwei metro entscheidungsfreudigkeit
zu tun haben aber jedes worüber oder
wozu dieser entscheidung ungeklärt
bleibt und dass an dieser stelle kein
ethisches moralisches problem sondern
ein technisch ist das aber dadurch
ethische dilemmata ungefragt vor
entscheidet das ist im übrigen der kern
des algorithmus dem gerade mit recht
viel aufmerksamkeit gewidmet wird wir
leben in der illusion dass die
steigerung von rechenkapazität die
probleme der chinesen wird dabei ist es
genau umgekehrt jetzt werden die
probleme erst eigentlich sichtbar damit
existenziell
egal ob supercomputer kühlschrank oder
smartphone wir sehen uns an der technik
gegenüber die nur zwei voraussetzungen
hat um zu funktionieren das macht auch
ihre effektivität aus erstens etwas muss
formalisierter sein also in eine formale
sprache übersetzt bei sein es muss
zweitens entscheid basel
letzteres beginnt bedingt erst aus da
wird etwas formuliert wird werden kann
also in eine formale sprache übersetzt
und dann algorithmisch aufgeführt werden
kann muss es entscheidbar sein
der computer ist die entscheid baka
schiene par excellence das bedeutet aber
auch dass er nicht nicht entscheiden
kann
der punkt ist also dass diese art der
entscheidung ohne semantik funktioniert
das ist es technisch gesehen kein
übergang gibt zwischen quantität und
qualität
dementsprechend ist sie eine rein
formale seiten von ihnen keine wahl in
diesem sommer ein computer rechnet aber
er versteht nichts entscheidet aber er
wählt nicht es wäre jedoch grundlegend
falsch und das möchte ich gerne betonen
weil wir immer ein bisschen vorgeworfen
wird ich bin kommen nur aus der
kritischen ecke und möchtest ganz so
verteufeln das ist nicht der fall im
gegenteil es wäre grundlegend falsch
dieser beobachtung sofort als eine art
von überlegenheit des menschlichen tuns
und denkens zu müssen
es geht hier nicht um eine ständige ist
um das stetige defizit aber ich finde es
sehr wohl wichtig diese grundsätzliche
andersheit dieses entscheids partick
massen beispiel gegenüber einer immer
sinn orientierten hermeneutischen
weltsicht stets vor augen zu führen
führen die da immer herangetragen werden
das problem heute schon ein paarmal
anthropomorphe probleme an etwas heran
getragen was eigentlich da ist da ist es
irgendwie kategorien fehler an
medientechniker kategorien fehler was
den algorithmischen medien fehlt ist die
entscheidung selbst jetzt kommt müssen
wir die kritische komponente der unfall
wird so zu einem permanenten
ausnahmefall in dem die entscheidung
autonom regiert das ist ein bisschen das
problem dass sich dahinter sehe so lange
das alles in so blackboxen verweilt die
die die algorithmische technik quasi
materialisiert solche ausnahmefälle
nennt man spätestens seit karl schmidt
ernstfall und ich kann hier nur andeuten
dass mit diesem namen eine richtung
angezeigt dass welche den technisch
implementierten neuzeitlichen
rationalismus in so ein genaues
gegenteil nämlich gucken ihrer zahlen
des umschlägen lässt sobald diese
technik unverstanden bleibt und damit
als scheinbar undurchschaubar
eigenständig agierende blackbox quasi
natural easyad das ist etwas was man
momentan beobachten kann und wo auch die
philosophie dann letztendlich ihre rolle
hat da einzugreifen
das problem beginnt dabei dass ersatz
vom ausgeschlossenen dritten eine wurzel
des entscheids paradigmas ist ein medium
dessen conditio sine qua non entscheid
bank
wien aris muss ist muss ein
kategorisches problem mit neun
finalisten haben aus diesem aber besteht
die welt zu großen teilen von der sprach
über die psychische realität des
menschen bis zur quantenphysik
mit der erwähnung der quantenphysik ist
übrigens schon an vielleicht ein
möglicher technischer lösungsansatz
genannt ich möchte am schluss noch mal
betonen das ist mir bei allem gesagt
nicht um eine ablehnende
fundamentalkritik algorithmischer medien
gehen ich könnte mir vorstellen ich
würde nur dafür plädieren die aus
unverständnis resultierende
anthropomorphe sicht auf diese medien
und dieses vorherrscht aufzuklären und
damit den blick frei zu bekommen auf die
erforschung des computers vielleicht als
welt zugang sui generis er ist
vielleicht und das ist ein bisschen
flächen gegenargument zu einem
wasserbecken heute morgen sagte er ist
nicht nur hilfs technik dass diese
assistenz geschichte mag sein und ist
auch dass auch da ist sicherlich viel
sehr viel überlegenswert ist dran ist
ganz wichtig aber vielleicht muss man
sich auch mal gemüt von der philosophie
her zu denken was sind die potenziale
eigener dignität die uns da gegenüber
steht die ist als solche jetzt erst in
den blick zu nehmen gilt also wir haben
heute schon jetzt bin ich auch am ende
schon wir können nicht sofort diskussion
über gehen
ich nehme alt als ein beispiel dafür die
digital humanities und ihren beginnen
bei franco moretti
wir kennen das diskont reading was is
close trading und so weiter oder heute
die karlschule analytics wie sie mit
leverage und dem und seinem lab
angefangen haben die versuchen halt zu
schauen welche fragen kann ich jetzt
überhaupt erstellen
na also dass das widerspricht auf keinen
fall der der der ko performance analyse
sondern aber man muss fragen nicht
gleich mit anthropomorphen fragen
demgegenüber stehen weil das verliert
der rechner dann immer genau wie es
umgekehrt der fall wir können halt nicht
so schnell rechnen also dieser die
rechnung gibt das ist das geht nicht auf
wir müssen halt schauen was ist das
eigene was was sind die fragen die jetzt
entstehen kann nicht die antworten
welche art von fragen kann ich jetzt
erst stellen also und beschreibt in
seinem kritik zum beispiel das ist in
seiner einfachheit berückend ne das sind
so fragen eine frage ist wie kann man
millionen bilder sehen
das ist also die idee die bilder die
überhaupt nicht mehr für das auge
gemacht also das menschliche auge
gemacht sind die registrierten messdaten
sind die millionen gleichzeitig
ausgewertet werden können
was heißt hier überhaupt sehen also
überhaupt oft zur frage zu kommen die
vorher mit bezug auf die sprache
gestellt wurde
welche welche fragen kommen wieder
welche fragen kommen auf wenn man an
wenn man aufhört ständig centro
profitieren weil ihre promo visierung in
diesem falle bin ich früher auch selbst
gegangen
resultiert immer in einer fahrt von
fundamentalkritik gut das ist das holz
von mir sein
nach einer halben stunde ok danke ihnen
für ihre aufmerksamkeit